so
[Music]
when spirit is at first conceived of as
substance in the element of pure thought
it is immediately simple and
self-identical eternal essence which
does not however have this abstract
meaning of essence but the meaning of
absolute spirit only spirit is not a
meaning is not what is inner but what is
actual
therefore simple eternal essence would
be spirit only as a form of empty words
if we went no further than the idea
expressed in the phrase simple eternal
essence
but simple essence because it is an
abstraction is in fact a negative in its
own self and moreover the negativity of
thought or negativity as it is in itself
in essence that is simple essence is
absolute difference from itself or it's
pure othering of itself
as essence it is only in itself or for
us but since this purity is just
abstraction or negativity it is for
itself or is the self the notion
it is thus objective and since picture
thinking interprets and expresses as a
happening what has just been expressed
as the necessity of the notion it is
said that the eternal being begets for
itself and other but in this otherness
it has at the same time immediately
returned into itself for the difference
is the difference in itself that is it
is immediately distinguished only from
itself and is thus the unity that is
returned into itself
paragraph
769 leads us once again into some rather
abstract
considerations a lot of hegelian
terminology
and
you might be forgiven for wanting to
you know skim past it rather quickly but
it's important that we see
what is actually going on here and i
think that we're aided in part by
lending it
a bit more specification a bit more
concreteness by
reading in what what has happened in the
paragraphs prior to this and thinking
about where we're going but also by
attending to something that hegel is
going to say
early on in this that that really has to
do
with badoytung or meaning as it's being
translated here meaning or you could say
referentiality what is it what is it
signifying what is it getting at
and
hegel here
sort of tells us listen this can't just
be abstract so
if there's one
phrase that maybe we should start out
with it's this one
therefore
simple eternal essence
would be spirit only as a form
of empty words if we went no further
than the idea expressed in the phrase
simple eternal essence so simple eternal
essence has a
meaning
right but it's a meaning that is
rather bloodless a meaning that's
abstract something that is
not quite what it ought to be
for us the phenomenologist following
along in the
development of consciousness
particularly in terms of this hegel's
talking about here
in terms of religion
and so hegel himself is telling us
listen don't
just
repeat the words you've gotta you gotta
think this through there's something
being worked out here and you know if we
go back to the previous paragraph where
it ends
he's telling us he talks about the
consciousness of the community the
gomanda possesses content for its
substance just as the content is the
certainty of the community's own spirit
so this paragraph 769 is following
directly
on that the community's own spirit is
what is in the background here
so he's telling us what we have to watch
out for and he says when spirit is this
is beginning the paragraph at first
conceived of as substance and the
element of pure thought so let's let's
stop there for just a moment
spirit conceived of okay the translation
here
may you know conceiving works although
we're not yet dealing with the concept
we are dealing with
for stellang right because it is
conceived of
for gestalt right so
better would be to say when if we want
to be like you know in
you could say in in consonance with how
this is term is being translated
elsewhere in this paragraph when spirit
is
pictured
picture thought picture language right
when spirit is represented
as substance
in the element of pure thought
so now we have a kind of seemingly
regression pure thought right
he goes on and he says it is immediately
unmediated
simple and self-identical eternal
essence so you know that's that's very
nice if you can get that
we have just a few paragraphs earlier
talked about how what we're doing
here is different than well actually
there's one paragraph before what's
different in the unhappy and believing
consciousness the unhappy consciousness
being of course the culmination of the
self-consciousness section the believing
consciousness being something that is
going to be eroded
by insight
and in in this the spirit section
leading ultimately to the enlightenment
so
you know if we can get this immediately
simple self-identical
eternal
um
essence that's that's awesome isn't it
um now we should also be careful here so
self-identical zeke zelps glicha okay
that's one way in which we could
translate it
but also we might pick a more dynamic
way
equivalent to itself you know equaling
itself zeke zelpst is a intensifier
it there's a relationality here so it's
not like
an identity in the sense that there's
only one thing there
it's an identity that conceals a
multiplicity
of what is made identical what is being
made like right
and we have the eternal aviga
so that goes all the way back to the
unhappy consciousness right
which is what the unhappy consciousness
has been seeking
essence vasen sometimes being translated
in earlier paragraphs as being
like in supreme being now actually being
called essen so spirit
being represented as substance
is for thought
you know for pure thought
this
uh ident you know simple self-identical
eternal essence and then he adds
something else important in there
which doesn't have this abstract meaning
the badoitong
of essence but the meaning the badoytung
of absolute
spirit
well that seems to be in advance again
right so it's not just substance it's
not just essence it is
absolute spirit the thing we've been you
know trying to not we could say we've
been looking for it this whole time well
spirit's been looking for itself this
whole time through
the human beings that are in fact a part
of spirit
right but then
hegel pulls another
interesting twist
only spirit is not a
meaning it's not a badoitong
why it's not a signification
not what is inner what is just you know
hidden inside but
is actual
or actuality
das virglika now notice he doesn't say
virtually kite he doesn't just say
veer clique as an adjective he says
spirit is das virklika so spirit is
something that has to be
actualized and this is something that
we've seen throughout the entire
phenomenology but it becomes more
and more
thematically evident
from
you could say the reason section into
the spirit section and it becomes very
much the case in the spirit section
the actual the real
we have to somehow turn
spirits or
representations or
essences or pick whatever you want
they have to become realized they have
to become actual so what does this look
like
here's where we we come to that phrase
that i had brought up earlier
simple eternal essence
would be spirit only as a form of empty
words
if we went no further than the idea
expressed
in the phrase simple eternal essence so
we gotta go
it doesn't mean that we get rid of the
phrase right we're not gonna go beyond
language itself
but
there's
something that has to be
added here something that has to be
thought out further something that has
to be
engaged with what is that so he says
simple essence
because it's an abstraction is in fact a
negative in its own self and moreover
the negativity of thought
well that's interesting
what happens when we think too
abstractly
we think that we're actually talking
about
something that has
actuality but
the thinking itself contains its own
negation
and a determinant negation not just a
simple canceling
but a there's got to be something else
here this this abstraction cannot be all
that we're
working with so he says um the
negativity of thought or
negativity as it is
in itself in
essence and then he goes on and explains
this further
simple essence is absolute difference
from itself or it's
pure
or absolute
othering right pure othering
of itself this all sounds rather
abstract as well though doesn't it
couldn't you say we've gone from you
know the old proverb going from the
frying pan into the fire going from
abstraction number one into abstraction
number two but this this
difference this othering
becoming other to itself
is referring to something that is a bit
more concrete
what is it referring to here's where we
need to substitute something else in
both in this paragraph and in the
paragraph to come that was in there
already where is this othering taking
place well partly in the community but
also partly through the incarnation the
externalization of god into a person
in religion
so this is quite important
all right going on
he says and now we're going to get these
sort of
phases that are going to come up again
in the next paragraph
as essence
as
vasen as this abstract eternal essence
it is only in itself
or for us
notice there that he doesn't say it is
in itself and then it is for us
there's no
sequentiality there
these are two sides at this point in the
phenomenological exposition of the same
thing it is in itself
and it is for us so the being that it
has
is a being that contains an inner in
itself and also
how it is
for us as the
observers but also as the worshipers
those who are engaged in religion and
then he says this purity
is just an abstraction or negativity
because of that
we have progress
it becomes
for itself
or is
the self
right the zelps
a person can have agency a person can
ask itself what am i am i man am i god
what is going on here a person can teach
other persons a person can be an
intermediary
for itself
which is also the notion the beginning
of
what we've been
seeking out through all of this
and what gets you there
well this is where we have
something very interesting coming up
it's objective gigensteinlink right
so it's an object for us
now notice what hegel brings in next
sense picture thinking
interprets and expresses right aussie
right it it
picture thinking
for stellang
uh things being four gestalt
this is providing us with a way of
understanding
what the for itself of the divine object
the divine
human
is going to be
picture thinking is not simply opposed
to the notion
it's also our way of entering into the
notion and what does he say here he says
picture thinking interprets and
expresses
what has just been expressed as the
necessity of the notion the note
vendikite right so there's necessity on
the side of the notion is this like pure
logical necessity no this is what we
might call a historical necessity a
going from contingency to necessity
and how does picture thinking
picture this
as a
happening
sheen
what takes place what what occurs
right what
becomes part of
history
the history we could say sacred history
but also cultural political all sorts of
history right
so
it moves from the in itself to the for
itself for us to for itself through
picture thinking and now remember back
who's picture thinking is this happening
through well look at the communities
right uh not just its own picture
thinking not just an elite of us you
know uncovering the real meaning of
christianity or something like that but
the community itself which we don't have
absolute control over
so he goes on and he says
because picture thinking
interprets this necessity as a happening
it is said that the eternal being begets
for itself and other it it
generates an other for itself and now he
says something different about this
other it's not really
a mere abstract other in this otherness
it has at the same time immediately
return into itself for the difference is
the difference
in itself
in in this this being that is also the
concept it is immediately distinguished
only from itself and is thus the unity
that has returned into itself with the
typical hegelian thing right there is a
rudimentary stage it others itself uh in
this case it's being mediated through
picture thinking then there's a return
to itself bringing in this
well-developed
you know progress
into what it itself is now if we want to
put this in sort of religious terms
um before itself the notion which is
what the
the god man of christianity
is all that for the community the only
it's not as if god incarnates god and
then teaches the community and the
community is just this passive
receptacle
no there's something else going on here
where there's a bit more agency on the
side of the community how does this work
well let's look at the
following paragraphs to see that
there are thus three distinct moments
essence being for self which is the
otherness of essence and for which
essence is
and being for self or the knowledge of
itself in the other
essence beholds only its own self and
its being for self in this
externalization of itself it stays only
with itself the being for self that
shuts itself out from essence is
essence's knowledge of its own self it
is the word which when uttered leaves
behind externalized and emptied him who
uttered it but which is as immediately
heard and only this hearing of its own
self is the existence of the word
thus the distinctions made are
immediately resolved as soon as they are
made and are made as soon as they are
resolved and what is true in actual is
precisely this imminent
circular movement
paragraph 770 like the preceding one it
sounds very abstract and metaphysical
and we have to say what what's actually
going on here in this you know imminent
circular movement and the three distinct
moments and all that what's what's
actually happening and so backing up to
the previous paragraph i think can be a
little bit helpful talking about you
know essence and then
the abstraction involved in that
uh it's in itself being for us and then
moving to
being for itself which gives us the
concept something that's
not just
for stellang or for gestalt that is
picture thinking or
conceived or imagined or whatever we're
going to view it as and so this begins
by talking about three distinct moments
and really what's being said in the
german is s unterscheid and zeke what's
the what's the s there i think
uh you know it's the process the dynamic
that spirit is going through
we can also think of it
in terms of the imminent circular motion
that he talks about kaizen right kais
is circle
we don't want to think of this as a
merely repetitive circular movement but
rather one that
encompasses a whole that brings about a
kind of
reconciliation so there are
three distinct moments
you could say it divides itself into
three distinct moments or it just
divides itself into three moments right
it distinguishes itself
into
three moments and what are these essence
being for self
right and being for self you might say
wait a second what the hell is going on
here you know
is there a difference between these two
beings for herself yes yes there is but
they're both called the same thing being
for self you know
through sign
and you might say well how how do we
have three moments here why don't we
just have two
moments well because there's a
difference there's a
a progress involved in the being for
self so we're exploring
the way in which
being for self in the concept is is
happening
but there's also another important thing
the essence
comes to know itself through this
being
for self right so let's follow it out
we've got three distinct moments let's
talk about each of these we've got
essence first of all
vasen
being for self what kind of being for
self being for self number one
which is the otherness of essence
and for which essence is
okay so this is
you know there's an al alteration going
on here becoming other and
this is the otherness of the essence
okay which is coming out of the essence
and
this is the being for self for which
essence is what is what does that
actually mean um
essence
is
turning out to be for itself in its
being for yourself in in the mode of how
it understands itself right okay so
that's
i think
easy enough to understand and then what
is the third
moment
well it is being for self or
the knowledge of itself in the other so
there's something different than merely
being for itself or othering itself
there's the
knowing itself
in this other
right so these are
are they different being for selfs
they're different aspects of being for
self different moments here things that
we can
distinguish you know until shyden from
each other
and what's going to be going on here
what's what's the
meaning the upshot of this so he goes on
and he says
essence beholds only its own self it it
intuits it it sees
only its own self in its being for self
in this externalization
right
of itself it stays only with itself
so
what's happening here essence turns out
to have contained a lot more than just a
simple essence that was being referred i
mean think about what was talked about
in the beginning of paragraph 769 which
we just looked through
immediately simple and self-identical
eternal essence right we saw that
this
isn't really what essence is
so
it's it's unfolding itself it's finding
more in there
but it's sticking with itself
right it's that's where it's central
focus is
and so it's
externalization
it's we can even say alienation it's
it's othering
of itself is giving us aspects
uh giving it aspects that it had not
before
realized he goes on and he says
the being for itself that shuts itself
out from essence right so the being for
itself that shuts itself off from
essence that's over here
is
essence's knowledge
of its own self
only
through
emptying of itself
is it going to truly know
what it is so now we have not just
othering
externalization
also you know
bringing you could say a void within
itself emptying itself
that is a real form of otherness and
thereby it can actually know what it
truly is and he says it is the word the
vort right which when uttered leaves
behind
externalized and emptied him who uttered
it okay
word
we're talking here about
a word is an expression right
we're also talking about the
biblical and theological word of
christianity that comes from john's
gospels right in the beginning was the
word and the word was with god and the
word was god
you know enjo logos
yeah the the the logos is the word in
this case verbum in in latin vort in
german and so
there's a difference between okay who is
the sayer the sayer is also the word
and the sayer is saying a lowercase w
word
and thereby emptying
itself right
bringing
a void into itself a layer
but then he goes on and he says
this is as immediately heard
and only this hearing
of its own self is
harry adds another
element
the existence the design of the word
right
it's not lost it is hearing itself it
appears to be
losing itself emptying itself
externalizing itself but this is exactly
how it gets itself back
right so that's an interesting
feature as well
now hegel makes it even more
interesting by saying that this is an
imminent circular movement and what
happens in this imminent circular
movement that is involving the existence
of the word he says the distinctions
made right the distinctions that we've
got here into three moments
are immediately resolved as soon as
they're made
and not only that and they're made as
soon as they're resolved so
there's a
a circularity here that is a different
kind of circularity than that of the
entire
process
these distinctions are being made by the
essence which is grasping itself
ultimately in knowledge right and then
externalizing itself and these
distinctions
as they're being made are being resolved
but as they're being resolved they're
also being
made again
so you can say well how's that happening
in this circular movement
and this is supposed to
help deepen what was going on in the
previous paragraph talking about this
otherness immediately returning into
itself this difference that is
distinguished only from itself you know
right we have this this circularity
going on here but this is supposed to
illustrate for us how we're going to
in some way or what is in some way
getting past
just representation or picture thinking
for
for stellen right
what is the concept here what is the big
if that is being developed the notion so
this is getting us a little bit closer
to that and then in the next paragraph
we're gonna see
there's more working out that's a bit
more concrete
to
to happen but this is setting the stage
for that
you